Life is a journey,
and you want to be excited
about what you're doing,
so find passion in it.
And if you find passion, as they say,
you'll never work a day in your life.
Shelli Brunswick,
thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm fantastic.
It's wonderful to join you today.
Thank you for inviting me.
And thank you to your sponsors
that make this possible.
Thank you very, very much.
That's very kind of you.
And good morning to you.
Thank you for taking this
on an early Sunday morning.
But we're going to have so much fun.
It's going to be the best Sunday morning
possible because we're going to talk
all about space, your passion.
I know practically nothing about space.
And I'm ultra curious.
So, I'm excited for this episode.
Shelli, If I were to even start by going
through your journey from the Air Force
all the way to the Space Foundation,
I'm not going to do it justice.
I'm going to ask you to briefly
take me through
your incredible experiences and so that
we can get into a deeper conversation
about space and where we're headed.
Well, thank you for that.
I always like to say
my journey has had three chapters.
And that first chapter
was right out of high school.
I enlisted in the US Air Force
and I was stationed in Europe.
And so I got to experience new cultures,
new people, new ideas.
And while I was working during the day,
I was a personnel office specialist.
So, HR, and at night I went to school.
So, I completed my bachelor's degree
going to school at night.
And after being enlisted for 12 years,
I applied and was selected
to become a Air Force officer.
So, that started my second journey.
And that's when I transitioned
into the aerospace and space industry.
Because I was stationed
at the Space and Missile Systems Center
in Los Angeles
and I became a space project manager.
So, that was really my start.
And then from there,
I had jobs working
at the Space and Missile System Center,
learning all about ground stations
and launch vehicles and on orbit assets.
And then I went and worked
at Defense Acquisition University.
I was a professor
teaching about space acquisition.
And then my final
assignment in the Air Force.
I was stationed on Capitol Hill
where I was a congressional budget
and appropriations liaison,
securing the budget for the Air Force,
as well as the space
portion of that budget,
and then answering questions
and helping everyone understand
the importance of space to our future.
And then, so that ends my second chapter.
And obviously, you know a little bit
about my third chapter,
and that's where I am today,
working at the Space Foundation
as the chief operating officer
and are executive leader for our Center
for Innovation and Education.
That's just remarkable.
One of the things that you mentioned was,
it sounds to resonate across your career
is what part of your role was also
explaining the importance of space
and how people can interact
with such a weird subject.
I mean,
99% of the things that we deal with
are here on Earth, and all of a sudden
we're dealing with things
that we can't even see,
feel or touch or hear.
And one of the things that we brought up
in our earlier discussion was how
a lot of people view space as
sort of like a black box. Right?
And as an engineer, when I get introduced
to a lot of code that sometimes
it's very complicated,
somebody else wrote it
and I just accepted it as it is.
And I'm too afraid
to even get into it and touch it
because it's so messy and complicated.
And I think that for me and my friends,
space is like that in some level.
It's too obscure,
it's too complicated out there.
So, maybe dumbed down a little bit for me
and talk to me a little bit about
what space really is all about.
Well, that's one of the
misperceptions about space.
There are three real misperceptions.
One is the technology piece of it.
Many people think about Elon Musk
and Jeff Bezos and launch vehicles
and satellites, and that is certainly
a part of the space industry.
But I read about your background as well,
and you're very sophisticated and smart
and you're doing a lot of things
that directly relate to space.
Because space is about
the Internet of things:
financial industry, agriculture,
health care, pharmaceuticals,
public safety, transportation,
communications.
There are 16 different technology sectors
that relate to the space industry.
And we're using them every day.
We're using it right now.
When we get down
we probably all going to look
at our cell phone.
Technology in your cell phone
came from the space industry.
And I share with you
two awesome
companies went public
and that was Uber Eats,
or DoorDash and Airbnb.
Again, two great companies
that are using space technology
to create a company.
So, when you think about it,
don't think about it like
this is space and it's a black box.
Think about it as,
how can I take this
this capability, this infrastructure
and how can I use it to unlock value,
release innovation and technology
to help better our lives on Earth.
So, I hope that helped a little bit.
And how exciting space is
and what really the space economy is.
So, Shelli,
why are you so passionate about space?
Why joined the Air Force
out of high school?
Why continue on the path?
And, you know,
you're touching the skies
with the airplane
and then you decide
to go even higher to space.
Why? Why even do that?
Why go that route?
Well, I have a value system that was
instilled from a very early age.
My grandmother, my mother, my aunts
we all come from a family of,
we really work hard,
we believe in doing what's right.
Integrity first, service before self.
And those are exactly the same traits
that the US Air Force has.
So, it was a natural path for me
to go into the Air Force.
I initially didn't think
I'd stay almost 30 years.
But I just loved what I was doing
and I'm passionate about everything I do.
I mean, life is a journey
and you want to be excited
about what you're doing.
So, find passion in it.
And if you find passion, as they say,
you'll never work a day in your life.
So, I love what I do.
I think the biggest piece for me is
I look at all the individuals that maybe
are not part of the space economy
and I highlight,
we have room for everyone.
Whether it's high school diploma, the PhD,
there's an opportunity for everyone
to be part of the space economy.
Talk to me a little bit about
where we are today, because I think
one of the remarkable things
that we've seen
in the past year or two is this explosion
of innovation and excitement
over what's been happening with space.
I know hundreds of thousands
are tuning in, live, practically daily
for the Space X launches.
Jeff Bezos has company Origins just
announced a partnership with NASA, right,
to deploy things to space.
So, where are we today in terms of either
space exploration or space technology?
You know, just to give me
a little bit of taste
so that I can get excited about it.
Awesome.
Well, let me give you
a little bit of taste.
I'm sure you're very familiar with GPS.
And when people think about GPS,
they think about airplanes
and they think about cars
and how do we get
from one place to the other.
But since 1983, GPS has unlocked
one point three trillion dollars
of value to our economy.
That's jobs.
That's economic opportunity.
And again, I shared with you
a couple of companies
that have just gone public
that are using space technology
to create a business.
So, get excited about that
because the other great part of GPS
is that was an investment
by the US government.
So, that infrastructure
was courtesy of the US government.
Anybody, anywhere in the world
can use GPS now to create a business
and be an entrepreneur.
The other great thing is,
the NASA Technology Transfer Office
has thousands of patents
that are waiting for entrepreneurs
to bring to market water purification,
growing food in austere conditions,
communications,
battery and storage technology.
So, you can go to the NASA
Technology Transfer Office.
And if you don't have an idea
on being an entrepreneur, you can take
and apply for one of their patents.
They also have seed money
to help you get started.
So, again, space technology
solves problems here on Earth
and makes our lives better.
And for anybody,
any of your listeners in Europe,
also, the European Space Agency
has the same thing,
the Technology Transfer Office.
So, if you want to be an entrepreneur
and you don't currently have an idea,
most entrepreneurs kind of have an idea,
you can go to either of those websites
and find a patent
and try to bring it public
and solve problems here on Earth.
I think that's just fascinating.
Because so many times
I'm watching my friends
go through this
really difficult ideation process
where they're sitting down thinking,
what can I invent or what can I do
to make a positive impact?
And even if I do think
I can make an impact,
can I even invent the technology
to go and do that,
let alone ready a patent about it?
And just hearing that you have
this obviously phenomenal agency
of superstars
that have already thought of,
these really obscure
and weird problems to solve,
such as water purification,
growing food on austere places,
and there might be open to you
in coming and making it
and productizing it
and making a business out of it.
I have to go check it out
because it's super, super cool.
But I have to ask, Shelli,
along your career did you anticipate
that you're going to become a space woman
and such a strong advocate?
You know, going to Capitol Hill
and advocating
for either its funding or support,
is this a path
that you imagined for yourself?
I would never have
imagined this for myself.
You have to remember,
when I started over 30 years ago,
the space industry was very different
than it is today.
When I started,
you work for the government
and it was really a few,
only a few countries
even had space programs.
And it was really about outer space.
Low earth orbit with
where the shuttle is,
satellites, ground stations.
Since the 80s, just to now
you can see the commercialization.
And it started with the right legislation
that allowed commercialization
of launch vehicles.
But it also showed
all this other technology.
And so, we've gone from a few countries
to over 80 countries are now part
of the space economy
and that's continuing to grow.
And it went from
where you work for the government
or maybe a large company
that works for the government
to now you can be an entrepreneur
and bring products to market yourself.
So, we've seen this democratization,
and the opportunity, again, for everyone
to be part of this space economy.
So, it's an exciting time for me.
There's no way little ShelLi Brunswick
could have imagined this,
but I'm excited and I look forward
to whatever the next thing is.
When people say,
"What do you think the next thing is?"
It's like, who could ever thought
GPS would be what it is today?
And so, it's exciting.
No, no, no.
That's just phenomenal.
So, Shelli, all of that
sounds super exciting.
And I never pictured,
and when I think of all
the different paths
that my career could take me,
I don't think that I
even considered space
as a viable option.
I think that, growing up as a teen,
a lot of the times
when we talk about space,
we immediately thought
of the connotation of being an astronaut.
And I remember that when I watched
the movie Hidden Figures, which I'm sure
that you're very familiar with,
I think it really transformed my thinking
about what different opportunities
there are to be as a scientist
and not necessarily as
as the athlete scientist
that is going up in the space shuttle.
And now, I'm definitely reconsidering
a lot of different paths
that I could take.
But Shelli, I'd love for you to tell me
a little bit about where we're headed.
What are the next steps
in either space exploration discovery,
scientifically speaking?
And what can I get excited about
for the next 10 years or so?
Well, it's really exciting.
What I do want to share is
the space economy is currently
424 billion dollars.
And that's projected to grow
one to three trillion dollars by 2040.
And Bank of America came out last month
and said they're predicting
the global space economy
to be one point three trillion dollars
by 2030.
So, there's lots of opportunity.
And that growth, again,
is not just going to be
in the launch vehicles and satellites.
It's going to be here on Earth
with data analytics and cyber
and miniaturization of technology
and advanced manufacturing
and health care.
So, you're going to see
this awesome explosion,
we'll use that term,
of space technology
being used in our daily life
here on Earth.
The Space Foundation
has a program we call
Space Technology Hall of Fame.
And every year
we recognize space technology
that has been commercialized
to help human beings on Earth.
This year we recognize telehealth,
telecommunications and teleconferencing.
All technology that came
from the space program
that has made this year of covid
even achievable.
Because when you think about health care
and communications,
without those forms of space technology,
this year of covid would have been
very, very challenging,
even more challenging than it is now.
And it is extremely challenging
for many folks.
I couldn't even imagine what would happen
if covid had broken out even
in the early 2000s, or even 10 years ago.
Right?
I mean, a lot of our ability to adapt
and to maintain to some degree,
our daily routine work,
work-life balance and family habits
are due to these technologies.
And so, it's very remarkable.
Tell me a little bit about
the Space Foundation
and your work over there.
Besides everything that we talked about,
you're also a role model
for so many women, whether it's through
the awards you received
or your mentorship
in the different programs
like Space4Women, I believe.
Right?
So, I would love to hear a little bit
about your work as a mentor,
but also as part of the Space Foundation.
Well, wonderful.
One of the activities I lead
at the Space Foundation is our
Center for Innovation and Education.
And that is all about
creative, inclusive,
sustainable programs
for workforce development
and economic opportunity.
So, all individuals can find their place
in the space economy.
And again, I shared with you
that's the entire workforce pipeline.
K through 12, teaching teachers,
reskilling the workforce
and then entrepreneurship.
So, we're looking at the
entire workforce pipeline
because to grow that space economy
one to three trillion dollars,
we need everybody to look at space
as a real opportunity.
So, that's why I'm out here
talking with you today
and thank you for giving me this chance
to get that awareness out there.
That space is possible for everyone.
We can help you find your way
into the space economy.
And then, we do have
a workforce development roadmap.
Awareness is number one,
which we're doing today.
Access, I just shared with you
one access point.
You know people
who want to be entrepreneurs, but maybe
are looking for that idea,
go to that NASA
Technology Transfer Office.
The third one is, even if you have
the desire to be in space,
you do have to have the right training,
whether that's a certificate
in advanced manufacturing
or cybersecurity
or data analytics or a PhD,
like you said, from Hidden Figures.
And then, you want to connect.
You want to connect
with like minded individuals,
join organizations
like the ones you mentioned.
WomenTech Network,
that's the organization
that I was honored to receive the
Diversity and Inclusion Officer/
Role Model of the year from.
They have a mentorship program.
The UN Office of Outer Space Affairs,
Space4Women,
I'm one of 35 women around the globe
that's part of that program.
And again, it's about mentorship
and connecting.
There's other programs,
Space Generation Advisory Council.
So, look for organizations
where you can connect.
And then the last step is
look for a mentor and be a mentor.
Because no matter where you are
in your career,
you can mentor someone else
and you can always look to be mentored
and coached as well
so that we can ultimately
reach our true actualization
of service before self and helping
to contribute to the greater good.
So, that tells you a little bit about
the Space Foundation and our
Center for Innovation Education,
as well as a couple of those programs
that I'm involved and that you mentioned.
I think that's wonderful, Shelli.
Thank you for sharing that.
What is the one biggest challenge
that you foresee us having with space?
Whether it's in education,
it's in the workforce,
whether it's, you know,
one of the things that I'm thinking
about is a lot of people are talking
that if a couple of hundred years,
we might actually be living
in a different planet.
How is the world today going to impact
as the government
as we see it in the future?
We see different countries
looking at different interests.
And I'm always curious about
who's thinking about this stuff?
You know, who's thinking about
whether my great grandkids
are going to be a part of government XY,
or whether it will be an anarchy?
Right?
So, those are great questions.
And the biggest challenge I see
that's immediately impacting us
as we look to grow in the space economy
in the next 10 to 20 years
is really that workforce.
Do we have the right individuals.
We have a skills deficit.
We have that innovation gap.
And we have a workforce shortage.
So, as I shared with you,
there are a lot of great opportunities
in the space economy.
We can't find enough workers.
And so, what that means is
some of the workers we have in the US,
maybe they're in inner cities
or rural communities
or they've never thought about
being part of the space economy.
We need to inspire them
to look for opportunities
to join the space economy.
During covid right now,
individuals to get recertified,
they could go through
a certificate program
and go into the manufacturing sector,
data analytics, cyber.
But right now we need that workforce.
And then we have, like I said,
the skills mismatch.
We have individuals
that are looking for jobs
and we have jobs available
in the space sector
in all those different industries.
But we have a mismatch of skills.
So, we really need to look at it.
And the Space Foundation
is one organization
that's out there talking about it,
but we really have to work together
to solve it.
Government, public private partnerships,
together we can work on
solving these challenges.
And then, of course,
as I shared that innovation gap,
we need entrepreneurs
who want to take that risk
and bring technology forward,
not only to create a job for themselves,
but to create jobs for others
and benefit humanity.
100%.
One of the things that
I'm seeing a pattern here
is this understanding
we're educating the market
in some sense, right?
When you're starting a new company,
when Airbnb started
using space technology, of course,
and they wanted people
to rent their houses
when they're not there,
they were really educating the market
with a new perception
and new thinking process.
Because previously it seems weird.
What? I'm going to let somebody else
live in my apartment while I'm away?
Or, I'm going to sleep
in somebody else's apartment.
Here, it sounds like
there's a similar challenge.
Where we have, you know,
a generation that needs,
the space workforce needs them.
But there is this misconception of
are we able to actually be
part of this workforce.
And it sounds to me like, yes, we are.
And now the question is,
how do we educate the market?
How do you think we should go?
Is this already
of the elementary middle school age?
Is it more the college level?
What's the sort of the thinking process
of getting this education?
Excellent. It's actually
the entire workforce pipeline.
So, you're right.
We need to look at kids
as young as possible.
Especially girls and minorities
who sometimes self eliminate
in middle school from thinking about
going into technology or space.
They don't see that
as a realistic career choice.
So, it's about taking
space inspired education
and putting it in the classroom.
And that's one of the things
the Space Foundation does through our
Center for Innovation Education is
we create space inspired education.
And we do a teacher training program
so that teachers can help coach
and mentor kids to stay on that track
so that they can go
into the space economy
in a variety of different areas.
And then we also, as I shared with you,
it's reskilling and upskilling.
So, we talk to various
workforce centers around the country
and talk about the importance of space
and how they can look
at training programs
with community colleges,
with universities
to reskill the workforce
as workers may be displaced by jobs
that are being automated,
as technology replaces workers.
And how they can have a great job
in the space economy.
And on average,
the jobs in the space economy
pay 40% above the median income
here in the US.
And then, of course, it's about
inspiring entrepreneurship.
We have many entrepreneurs
that are women or minorities,
but many times they don't think about,
"I could be a space entrepreneur".
And so, again, it's about
breaking down that perception that
everyone can have an opportunity
to be an entrepreneur
in the space economy.
Whether that's food service,
fleet maintenance
services provided through accounting, IT,
all the way up to PhDs
and mathematicians.
There's an opportunity.
And some of the programs we've done
at the Space Foundation
specifically do just that.
We have a junior space
entrepreneurship program
to inspire middle school
and high school kids
to look at being entrepreneurs
and taking space technology to market.
We also have our
Space Commerce Entrepreneurship Program,
which is for adults,
for entrepreneurs to look at,
how do I find an idea?
I can go to the NASA
Technology Transfer Office.
Or do I have a business
but I want to create another line
that I can sell to the aerospace
and space industry.
And so, we help them walk through
what is it to create
another line of business
or to be start a new company.
So again, it's that entire workforce.
There's a place for everyone.
And we have to be, as you said,
breaking down those barriers
that prevent individuals
from thinking about joining us
in the space industry.
Shelli, it's inspiring
and it makes so much sense.
And I'm definitely have to do
some rethinking on my own
on how I can be a part
of this space economy.
Because it just sounds like, you know,
first of all,
I probably am a part of the space economy
in one way or another,
just by virtue of being
in all those other industries
that we mentioned
in the beginning of this episode.
But I'm excited to take
a more active step
and re-educate myself
about what it means to be
to potentially be
a part of this workforce
or be a space entrepreneur.
Who knows.
So thank you very much
for this inspiration.
It was phenomenal talking to you.
I know how busy you are.
So, thank you for being
so generous with your time.
And I have to ask you
the most difficult question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
I think I said them a few times
during the podcast.
But obviously inspirational.
We need to inspire other individuals
to join us in the space economy.
So, I would say
I strive to be inspirational.
Innovative.
It's all about new technology
benefiting life here on Earth.
So, I believe innovation.
And then obviously, agile.
The first two are great
being inspirational and innovative.
But you got to be agile
and you got to get out there
and get it done.
And if you're not successful
the first time, get after it again.
So, those would be the three ways
I describe myself.
And I would describe you as
you are part of the space economy.
And I'm grateful for the contributions
you're making to make
space a better place
for everyone here on Earth.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that very much.
So, Shelly, thank you.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And hopefully we'll see each other
in space one day.
I look forward to it.
I'll meet you on Mars.
Definitely.
Thank you very, very much.